excited and uh he's nearly  there and magnus is so ruthless when it  comes to these type of positions  and he has this ability ability as  almost super human just to keep himself  calm  yeah so white's queen did give check  black's rook had to block now the bishop  steps back  attacking the black queen is that queen  trapped it's almost trapped right now  actually maybe it is trapped the black  queen about to drop off the board as  well  this is yeah this is magnus in top form  he's in the flow he's finding these  difficult moves quite quickly as well  yeah he's just been brilliant with  attacking the just pieces and i have to  say actually he  actually did a chessable course on how  to attack  without sacrificing pieces well worth  a check out and uh resigns yeah the  black queen about to be trapped  it's over magnus carlsen is the winner  of the semi-final against raj above he  is ready  for the big final in the third major in  the multiple champions chess tour  the fdx crypto cup